hi and welcome to my latest leaders
briefing it's the November Edition now
and we're only one month to go until
Christmas and it'll be my last leaders
briefing of the year and the next
Edition and we've recently
um commemorated Remembrance Day here at
our offices at Mill Lane and also around
our Leisure centers across the district
and I really hope that all of the
commemoration events went really well
across the parishes throughout the
district now hopefully you've received
our latest edition of the Northeast
Derbyshire news magazine it should have
dropped through your left a box now and
if it hasn't do it it hasn't done yet it
will do any day now there's lots of
features in there there's news about
killer Marsh active which is now up and
running and open and we've got the
library open within the building there
there's some also some news around what
else is happening in some of our Leisure
centers and some other key achievements
that we've been working on in recent
months but a big feature within the
Northeast establishing news magazine is
around the cost of living now we know
how much local residents are feeling the
pinch on this and businesses and how
it's affecting all of our day-to-day
lives now clearly the government is
putting in place a lot of financial
support and there's various different
packages and there's information within
our North established news magazine
around all of those different schemes
that are available
and as a district council we feel our
best best way of supporting our
residents and businesses is to really
give practical advice and support around
how we can all collectively reduce our
energy use safely and whilst also
maintaining the heat that we need to
keep ourselves warm so there's some
really good features within the
Northeast Derbyshire news magazine
really would encourage you to to have a
look at it and check out the website as
well we've got a big page around the
cost of living on the website huge
amount of work going on within the
council and with wrinkled homes our
housing Partners to really support our
residents we want to be here for you and
the key message to all of you is that if
you or anyone you know needs any
specific support please do get in touch
we are really you know we stand ready to
help as much as we possibly can and do
please get in touch if you know anyone
who you think might might need our
support but who perhaps might not reach
out themselves please do get in touch
and then sticking with the theme of
Energy Efficiency we're also running a
consultation together with the other
District and Borough councils and the
County Council around Energy Efficiency
improvements to our homes you'll find
more information on this about on our
website and how you can take part in the
consultation but we'd be really
interested to hear from you about ways
in which we as local authorities in the
area can work together to try and
improve Energy Efficiency in our homes
which is obviously going to help us all
to deal with issues like the energy
bills but also our Collective carbon
footprint and helping us to reduce our
carbon emissions as a county as a whole
and moving on to some other news you
might be aware from our from our news
magazine and also the social media that
we've suspended green waste collections
as we always do for the winter so we
suspend we've suspended them from Friday
the 11th of November in the northern
area of the district and then from
Friday the 18th of November in the
southern part of the district and that
will last for a few months and in March
um you you will we'll obviously reopen
them and please do check out your bin
calendars you should have hopefully by
now have had those through if not it'll
be with you anytime very soon but do
keep a lookout for those as well for our
Christmas collections there's always a
bit of a bit of tweaking around the
Christmas holiday period so do please
check on those and and obviously don't
forget to put the bins out myself and
the deputy leader of the council also
spent a shift a day shift each with some
of the refuse collection teams and it
was a really fantastic experience it
absolutely poured it down with rain on
my shift where I I did some bins in
drumfield lunston and cutthorpe
unfortunately for cancer Cupid she had a
fairly dry day I wasn't so lucky but it
was a really fantastic experience it was
great to walk a mile in in the shoes of
art or several miles if you like in the
shoes of our refuse collectors and
really really understand a bit more
about what they have to do and it made
me really really grateful and
appreciative for the work that they do
day in day out to do something as simple
as keeping our bins emptied and what a
mess we would be in without them so I
want to say a really big thank you to
all of our refuse teams and all of our
street scene Services who do some
fantastic work to keep the districts
looking clean and tidy you know and it's
great to be able to show a bit of
appreciation for them and and and
demonstrate really how what they have to
go through on a on a daily basis so well
done to them and a particular thank you
to the teams that looked at looked after
Charlotte and myself during the recent
the recent outings we'll be back out
again and actually in a couple of weeks
time I'll be I'll be spending some time
with some of our Leisure Center staff as
well to understand a bit more about
their work and how they how they're
getting on and we're doing a range of
these back to the floor sessions over
the coming weeks to just really get get
to grips with what our staff are having
to do in terms of some of the services
that we deliver so you'll be finding
more out about that in future briefings
I'm sure as I've mentioned in previous
leaders briefings we're taking a lot of
tough action on issues like flight
tipping and littering and we're really
trying to get to grips with some of the
issues that that residents across the
districts are experiencing and really
trying to make sure that we clean and
tidy up our beautiful countryside
surroundings and so a few of the things
that we've been doing we've had some
high profile prosecutions we've seized
and crushed the vehicle and issued some
pretty hefty fines we've also increased
the the the fines that we distribute to
the maximum possible allow amount that
we're allowed to set them at and we're
also doing things like deploying CCTV in
hiding CCTV and known fly tipping
Hospital spots to try and catch the
perpetrators while they're in the act
and we quite recently had a prosecution
successful prosecution of 300 pounds to
a waste collector who failed to provide
the necessary documentation for
collecting and disposing of waste and
this is a really useful reminder
hopefully that serves to all businesses
and all residents that if you pay
someone to collect your waste you must
check that they have the proper
documentation or else actually you could
be liable yourself so really do check
check into that and look into that and
be really careful about that and
obviously you know I hope you'll support
us in our efforts to really crack down
and get really really tough on fly
tipping and littering we can't allow it
to Scourge our communities in the way
that it has done in the past
now recently myself and the chair of the
council councilor Diana Ruff as well as
a senior officer went to an event an
armed forces event at the National
Memorial Arboretum to collect our Gold
Award now you may have heard about this
in previous editions but we won this we
wanted only 550 Employers in the whole
country out of about 7 million to have
been awarded the Gold Award as part of
the Armed Forces Covenant and this is
really about all the work that we do to
support the Armed Forces community and
reservists who work for the council so
really really pleased and really proud
of the council to be able to go and
collect that award and a big thank you
as well to our Armed Forces Champion
councilor Martin Thacker for all the
work he's done in in driving it forward
as well but it was great to be able to
go there and to receive that award along
with a few other councils in the area
which was really pleasing to see and
lots of other employers so great award
great event to be at and thank you very
much to the Armed Forces Community for
all of their support in terms of our
application you might also be aware that
the chair of the council councilor Diana
roof has a chair's appeal this year as
we always do and Diana's charity of
choice this time is safer the Armed
Forces charity now Dan is also hosting a
70s themed Disco Night at uh sherland on
the 2nd of December she's selling
tickets on our website so if you are
able to to join her for that event and
help contribute to a really valuable and
worthy cause please do go along please
go on our website and have a look about
how you can secure your tickets as I say
it'll be a fantastic night lots of great
tunes on and a good opportunity to to
contribute to this fantastic cause as
well now obviously following the very
sad passing of her majesty Queen
Elizabeth the Queen's green canopy
scheme has continued it was King
Charles's uh view that the schemats
continue and we're really we're really
pleased to be invited along with all the
other districts and Borough councils to
plant I think it was eight trees uh
Country Park is a special sort of cops
in memory of the queen and it was great
to be there to see some local
organizations honored as part of that as
well landmarks College based in
eckington was one of the recipients of
one of the trees and got to got to be
there as part of the tree planting as
well as well as a range of other
organizations and it was great to be
there and great to be part of a really
fantastic event to help honor the queen
and also to plant more trees it's a big
Derbyshire ambition at the minute to try
and plant a million trees over the next
few years so this is going some small
way to helping achieve that and for a
really good cause in memory of our
fantastic at Lake Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II so thanks very much for
watching this latest leaders briefing I
hope you found it useful and and you
picked up some useful information there
as I said at the very beginning please
do go on our website for more
information particularly around the cost
of living but also in relation to all
the other things that I've covered in
the briefing there's lots of information
on the website and please do follow
followers on our social media channels
Facebook Twitter and the like and I look
forward to seeing you next month where
we'll be talking a bit more about
Christmas thanks very much